let me let me pull up the story from
timcast.com
law professor says Senator hawley's
question about pregnancy opens trans
people to violence during Senate
Judiciary Committee hearing I watched
this video and I said I I saw two things
I saw the right wing sharing the C-SPAN
video saying can you believe this I saw
the left wing sharing the same video
saying can you believe this the left
overtly supporting this woman and the
right overtly supporting Holly let me
see if I can I can play this professor
Bridges you said several times you've
used a phrase I want to make sure I
understand what you mean by it you've
referred to people with a capacity for
pregnancy
would that be women
many women CIS women have the capacity
for pregnancy many CIS women do not have
the capacity for pregnancy they're also
trans men who are capable of pregnancy
as well as non-binary people who are
capable of pregnancy so this isn't
really a women's rights issue it's a we
can recognize that this impacts women
while also recognizing that it impacts
other groups those things are not
mutually exclusive Senator Hawley so
your view is I I got a pause right there
because it's this thing they do on the
left like aoc's done this where they do
this trail of Senator Hawley like AOC
did that with the refugees thing legal
asylies are not refugees it's like dude
okay man come on make your point you
know is this right then is about what
so I want to pause right here and just
say this
they're talking about women's rights
they're talking about pregnancy Holly
asks a straightforward question what do
you mean by people who can get pregnant
and she says a bunch of people he says
okay so it's not a women's rights issue
which is a legitimate and fair question
it's a pregnant people issue and the
woman still gives him the business yeah
this also happened uh Ilana Omar was
talking about pregnant persons
um you had Javier Becerra with HHS
talking about birthing people you had
Corey Bush discussing an extremely
difficult birth that she had with her
children uh talking about how she was a
birthing person talking about black
birthing bodies things like bodies
they're so in Houston
and I think that it actually
um it helps to drive people away from
this argument because they look at it
and they're like no you mean women and
everyone's like no we mean something
sort of amorphous or as Macy Gray said
it's a Vibe yeah
yeah she she walked back her comments
that women were you know adult human
females and instead decided to say that
being a woman they're talking about
total shortages I say we need them do
you think any of this would exist if
everyone was hungry do you think someone
would yell at me about me misgendering
them if I had a loaf of bread and they
did not and was offering some none of
that would exist none of this would
exist Adrian I think they I think well
so anyway well then you ain't getting no
help and then I think they would
probably steal your I think they would
probably steal your bread good luck
there was a there was actually over the
over the weekend
um in New York City a 14 year old boy
was stabbed on the subway on 137th
Street he stabbed to death by a group of
girls that were trying to rob him whoa
oh New York so here's what I was saying
the other day
I want to put on Skate contests
obviously the contests we would put on
would adhere to a male female standard I
we I wouldn't do mixed you know events
and I'm talking to some people like okay
what if we did an event and we were like
we'll be on a normal contest we'll find
a good Park we will pay for the
construction of a small skate park we
donate the skate park afterwards to the
community and then you know we get
sponsors and stuff help cover the costs
both Amanda's division of women's
division and I was told a lot of people
aren't going to want to come because of
the political implications and I was
like we'll do it we'll we'll do a good
cash prize like I think it'll be okay
and they're like no I don't know and
then I was like 10 grand
okay now they'll all show up yeah so
these people who are like posting these
Instagram videos saying things like you
know we gotta we gotta be respect the
trans women who are competing against
biological females because it's all here
and then I'll be like for 10 grand would
you come and participate in my event we
don't allow that they would say you bat
thank you may I have another yeah
because these people don't actually care
about principle they care about money
and the reason why they're supporting
these movements is because the
corporations and the sponsors are saying
this is what we want if you want to stay
on payroll well if I offer up a counter
payroll they will change their position
because like I said these are people of
weak mental fortitude of weak will this
is what I've been saying for years about
um Arts culture in the U.S so when
you're an artist and you're a young
person you want to make money for your
art and so you uh submit for Grants you
submit for prizes and all of these
things and most of the prizes are like
if you you know these prizes are open to
non-binary genderqueer or blah blah blah
blah and you have to like go on and on
with whatever your identity is they're
open to your identity they're open to
plays about given identities or what
have you and so if you change that if
you start offering uh prizes and grants
for other kinds of values you will get
work that represents those other values
the only reason you're getting so much
of this garbage is because that's what's
being funded so artists just do what
Their artists do what they're told I
mean that's the dirty secret about
artists for the most part they will do
what they're told so long as they get
paid to do it so just pay them to do
something else and they'll they'll take
their talent and do whatever you want
I'm sure you have some of what I have
which is all these famous faces that say
one thing and then they're like hey I
agree everything you say Adrian oh dude
yeah and I'm like you I cannot say the
word
yeah I hate those people and they're
like I hate them so much I secretly
agree with you I just can't say anything
publicly and you're like you know what
if everyone would just tell [ __ ] if
everyone just speak up speak their piece
then none of this would be happening it
would end tomorrow no one has to be
quiet let me do it because they want to
be quiet I want to show you this comic
that's been going around Kate Andrews
tweeted this uh Taylor Silverman
retweeted it and it's a woman being
burned at the stake and the guy says I
can't I completely agree with you oh my
gosh accurate well what I can't say it
publicly because I need to make that
cool can we put that on your Tombstone I
was a coward and I needed that cash do
you I don't even I I have a bunch of
like prominent uh I shouldn't say much a
handful of like La celebrities actors
you know movies TV show musicians they
hit me up and they're like man you know
like I I agree with you so much and I'm
like dude you've got more followers than
me you could just like you don't even
need to say something like I support
Donald Trump you could just very simply
be like whoa what's this story about can
anyone explain it to me just to at least
make sure your fans know it's happening
and then you're like oh I don't know
it's just a story from ABC about trans
kids I just was sharing it I I don't
know
the ones that aren't activists that only
like posted the black Square because
everyone was like pressuring them the
ones that just does that like you know
I'm obliged to do this one thing or this
two thing but they're not activists
they're all like us they're just cowards
I know about the black Square too it's
like if you posted the black Square then
um and you were like a white person then
that was an issue too because you were
taking up space Oh I got bullied I did
it in like two seconds later I took it
down I was like this is stupid but you
got bullied either way you got bullied
for not doing it and bullied for doing
it oh I've been on a tour of Fu I've
ever experience it's so stupid yeah you
just gotta not care like uh it's funny
um the the the Patriots dot win which is
the big Trump Forum they routinely
insult me they call me a [ __ ] and a
bunch of other names because I'm like a
fence sitter and I don't give Trump
enough support
but it's funny because I made a video
and I said I said something like you
know you want to know how you know the
left is a cult for one you can look at
the journalist and see they only consume
left wing news but on the quote unquote
far right whatever they want to call it
Trump supporters will call me a [ __ ] and
a bunch of other names but still be like
if he's got a good guest on will watch
and they posted saying like Tim thanks
us for calling him a cuck because
every single Tim pool insult now on
patreon thank you
I mean whatever like the thing is like I
don't I'm not gonna cry about Trump
supporters being mad at me I was just
like yeah they're mad at me I'm not
gonna cry about leftist being mad at me
it's the internet right exactly
everyone's Maddie the left doesn't
doesn't have any and like uh and this is
again when I say the left I'm speaking
generally not every single person but
they have this they can't tolerate any
DVD deviation from The Hive it's it's
outright creepy I mean we've said that
ad nauseam at this point but that's the
reality well the interesting thing too
is they say that it's all the
counterculture right like they push
pride and all of these things and they
it's all framed out as though it's a
counter-cultural movement but it
actually is the dominant culture and it
demands adherence just like any dominant
culture before it well so so here's a
meme I so I just want to share with you
guys and it's the Skinner Meme and he
says uh he says maybe I'm an NPC no
having the same opinions as celebrities
and major corporations while repeating
every media talking point verbatim is
what real people do maybe I'm the NPC
yeah he almost broke free he thought
about it for a second and said no no
when Amazon and Walmart say it that's
edgy I think I think that Jordan
Peterson would tell you that this is
because these people are possessed by
ideology they are not you lose a good
dose of your Humanity when you give
yourself over to an ideologue position
and you lose like the you very much lose
the ability to think independent and I
think that's why we see the ground news
where so much of the left is just
possessed by only supporting the left
wing and the hive mind like Tim is
talking about it's 100 ideology thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there